-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor
who you know from his work
as Peter Parker
from both
the "Spider-Man" movies
and the "Avengers" franchise.
His latest film, "Uncharted,"
is in theaters and IMAX now.
Let's take a look.
-Do you think
it's another puzzle?
-Well, whatever it is,
you better figure it out fast.
I'm gonna try
and buy us some time.
Hey, can I get you a drink?
-Gin and tonic, por favor.
-This definitely isn't a gin and
tonic, but it is on the house.
-Gracias.
-Hey, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let me guess, pi a colada?
[ crowd gasps ]
-[ grunting ]
-The eye.
-Think you're a comedian there,
sunshine.
-Okay, I got it, I got it.
Sex on the Beach.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Tom Holland,
everybody.
[ cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, my friend.
-Hello, mate.
It's good to be back.
-It's great to have you here.
Last time you were here --
[ cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
-This is very appropriate
because, you know,
last time you were here,
you were promoting
the new "Spider-Man" film.
-Yes, I was, yeah.
-And it's done quite well
for itself.
-Yeah, the studio were happy.
-Yeah.
It's interesting,
with your show,
I feel like you can do a, like,
through the ages
of me growing up.
I came here, I don't know,
I was maybe 19.
I'm 25 now.
-Yep.
-It's always great
to be back here, mate.
So thanks for having me back.
-And every time you come,
I say to you --
I'm like, "I don't think
it's going to work.
I don't think show biz
is going to work for you."
And you keep ignoring me,
and I'm so happy.
-Yeah, constantly
[bleep] myself.
-But a tremendous -- I mean,
a movie that is so deserved.
And one thing, of course,
every time you're here,
especially if it's for anything
Marvel, one of the problems is,
you have to promote a film that
you can say very little about.
-Very true, very true, yeah.
I am a very honest person
just by nature.
-Yeah.
-Which has got me into trouble
in the past.
-Yeah. It seems like
you're even nervous now
you're going to spoil a movie
that everyone has seen.
-That is already out there.
-Yeah.
-But every time I say, like,
"So Tobey --"
I'm like, "Shh, shut up,
don't say that."
But yeah, I'm just very honest.
So on the press tour, you know,
journalists are like,
"So were Tobey and Andrew
in this movie?"
I'm like, "No, they're not.
Stop asking me that."
And I go home
and I almost can't sleep
because I feel so bad
for lying all the time.
-Yeah.
-I'm, like, calling up my mom.
I'm like, "I just feel so guilty
for all the lies."
[ laughter ]
-Have you -- You should just go,
you should call
all those journalists
and be like, "I'm so sorry."
-I know, yeah.
-"I feel terrible about it.
I hope you understand."
-Yeah, I don't feel that sorry,
though.
-Yeah.
[ laughter ]
What was -- I mean, that is the
spoiler that could not be said
that we can now
let the world know.
But what was it like to work
with Andrew and Tobey,
the previous Spider-Men?
-Honestly, mate, it was
the most incredible experience
of my career.
To share the screen with them --
You know, playing Spider-Man,
while being
a wonderful experience
and, like, completely
life-changing,
it also can be quite alienating.
You know, when you're 19
and someone gives you
this opportunity
and your life changes,
it's quite hard to figure out
how to navigate.
So to almost have
like two older brothers
that had been through it
before me,
to be able to share
that experience with them
was amazing.
And I remember we were
shooting this scene,
which was really emotional --
like, a really,
really emotional scene,
and I was struggling to find the
emotion just because, you know,
when you make these big movies,
it can take two days
to shoot a scene.
I'd been crying for days on end.
So I went up to Andrew
and Tobey --
I nearly said Spider-Man
and Spider-Man.
[ laughter ]
And I basically just said,
"Thank you,
thank you for being here.
Thank you for taking the time
to be a part of this, you know,
incredible opportunity.
It means the world to me."
And we all embraced,
and we all started crying.
And I remember the writers
sort of seeing that,
being like, "Yep, that's how
we're going to end the film.
[ laughter ]
That's brilliant.
Well done, Tom."
And then the end of the film
is us having this moment
where I'm like,
"Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it."
And then we have this
beautiful hug, so it was's nice.
-That's really great
that you can both talk about
the experience
of playing Spider-Man,
which is obviously unique
to you guys,
and also wearing
the Spider-Man suit.
Because not a lot of people,
you know, do it at that level.
It's just, like,
the three of you
and that guy in Times Square.
-I'll give you a spoiler.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You don't want to hug him.
Do not hug him.
-I'll give you a spoiler,
and I'm not going to
tell you who,
but one of us has a fake ass
in their suit.
-Really?
[ laughter ]
Wow.
-You can figure out that
for yourselves.
-Well.
I mean, see, this is a real --
This is, you know --
Everybody thinks you're
such a nice guy,
but you're all about
ticket sales.
Because now everybody
is going back out
to try to find the fake ass.
-I remember being on set
and being like,
"Wow!
Oh, hang on a minute.
No, that's not real."
-Right?
At the wrap party, you're like,
"Where'd his ass go?"
-Yeah.
[ laughter ]
-This is -- This is very fun,
to do a film like this.
And I want to mention the clip
real quick.
You actually looked like
you had some bartending skills.
And I asked about it,
and you actually did
take this seriously.
You did a little bit
of bartending classes.
-Yeah, it was
an interesting one.
Nathan Drake as a character
is someone
who is incredibly capable
but in no way, shape,
or form trained.
So I wanted to find something
where I could convince
the audiences of his skill,
and I'd seen on YouTube
this flair bartending,
and I thought it was always
really cool.
So I thought that would be
a great way
to demonstrate to the audiences
that he's quite handy.
So I started taking
bartending classes,
and I actually went
to my favorite bar in London
and managed to convince
the bartenders
to let me go behind the bar.
So I ended up working these
kind of undercover shifts.
I had, like, the white tuxedo on
and everything.
-Yeah.
-But then the management team
found out, and I haven't
been allowed back since.
-In what -- in what --
I was going to say when
you had to convince them,
like, in what world do people
say, "No, Tom Holland.
You don't have your
bartender's license."
-I think the big part of it
was that, like,
they're charging a lot of money
and my drinks taste like [bleep]
-Oh, I see.
-And the patrons weren't happy.
-Yeah, like on Yelp,
they were like,
"While the espresso martini
was made by Tom Holland,
it tasted like [bleep]"
Three stars.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I have more questions
about "Uncharted."
We'll be right back with more
from Tom Holland.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Tom Holland.
Last time you were here,
right before the holidays,
we were talking about
you had not had time
and, obviously,
you're a busy guy,
to finish your Christmas
shopping for your family.
I know you're very close
to your family.
You always have at least
one brother with you
when you come here.
It's very nice to see him.
Did you get it done? Did you get
your Christmas shopping done?
-No.
-Okay.
[ laughter ]
-Thank you for bringing that up.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just honestly,
I'd finished the "Spider-Man"
press tour and I was so busy
and I was so tired,
that I just didn't do it.
[ laughter ]
And that's terrible.
That's terrible.
I've told my family and they're
already in agreement
that next year will be
a double gift year.
-Oh, wow! So they're
basically -- Yeah, okay.
-Yeah, put your orders in now
and I'll sort you out.
Don't worry.
-So they're ultimately
patient with you.
They're not
too judgmental of it.
-No, of course not.
I mean, my family are wonderful
and they know how hard I work
and the traveling
and, you know, like, you know,
the press tours are tough.
It looks really glamorous
and it is very glamorous --
I'm not complaining,
but I am complaining.
[ laughter ]
Because it's really tiring.
-That's the part that's the most
remarkable to me.
We always talk backstage
because people don't understand
that it's almost exactly as long
as it takes to shoot a movie,
especially a movie the size
of movies that you're making,
you have to go out and then talk
about them forever.
-Yeah. And, honestly,
I'm so sick of my own voice.
-Yeah.
-It does get to that stage.
We'd finished work the other day
and I bumped into someone
in a bar
and they asked me
about "Uncharted"
and, immediately, I just went
into press mode,
like "It's a movie
that ticks all the boxes.
It's funny. It's exciting."
[ laughter ]
And I was like,
"Stop talking like that!"
-And then, at the bar, did the
manager come over and go,
"Back to work, Holland!"?
-Yeah.
[ laughter ]
-Now, "Uncharted" --
this movie came about
because you wanted to play
sort of a young James Bond.
Is that right?
-Yes. Yeah.
It didn't work out quite
as planned.
[ laughter ]
-But this is that kind
-No, essentially, I just --
I'm such a big fan
of James Bond
and I, you know, I've loved
Daniel Craig's movies
and I just thought,
if they were to move on,
it would be really exciting
to see like how James Bond
becomes James Bond.
So I pitched this idea
for a movie,
which is kind of a stupid idea
where, essentially,
you wouldn't tell the audience
that it was a James Bond movie
until the end,
but from a marketing point
of view, that's a nightmare.
[ laughter ]
Like that just doesn't make
-And you would never be able
to keep that secret.
-No, mate.
If I got cast as Bond,
I'd be like,
"I am James Bond," tweet.
[ laughter ]
But, no, Tom Aspinall
really liked the idea
and, you know, they've been
trying to crack the case
with "Uncharted"
for a long time.
You know, there's been loads
of different actors.
Mark Wahlberg, at one point,
was going to play Nate
and now he's old,
[ applause ]
so he plays Sully.
-Yeah. This is sort of like
breaking Hollywood news,
that Mark Wahlberg is old now.
Is that what you're saying?
-Oh, yeah.
[ laughter ]
No, I've been saying that
on all the press tours.
It's been really fun.
-It seems like, yeah.
Mark Wahlberg seems like
a person that you would,
as a costar, that you would be
able to tease relentlessly
back and forth
because I would imagine
he gives it
as well as he takes it.
-Yeah.
You can tease Mark,
but he's also quite a scary guy.
-Yes, he is.
[ laughter ]
-So like I have a security guard
who's one of my best mates,
but I only tease Mark
when Jack's around.
[ laughter ]
I'll be like --
No, I'm not going to say
what I was going to say.
[ laughter ]
-Yeah. [indistinct] right now
if I was like,
"Well, Jack's not here,
but Mark is."
I'd be like, "Jack!"
[ laughter ]
-We've talked in the past
as well about, you know,
this is another big film,
great action.
There's a stunt in this film
that I want to ask you about
because, obviously,
you're no stranger to stunts,
but I've never seen somebody --
You are in mid-air
and you get hit by a car.
-That's true.
-[both] Yeah.
-Now, how do they bring that
to you as an idea
and then you just call
your stunt man right away
and say, "Bad news"?
[ laughter ]
-Yeah, I dunno.
It's one of those things where
this, for me,
as a young kid growing up,
the Indiana Joneses
of the world
was my favorite genre of film.
-The best.
-So, to do it myself
was really exciting,
but then, I had to do it
and I broke myself.
Like they tell you, "Right,
we're going to do this stunt
where you're going to jump
into the back of an airplane
and then you get hit
by a car out of the airplane."
And you're like, "Wow!
That sounds amazing!"
And then you shoot it
and you're on take 12
and like, "Can we go again?"
And you're like, "No!
I'm done!"
[ laughter ]
But it was tough.
I was actually on set
on "Spider-Man,"
pitching the movie to Zendaya.
I was going through the film
scene-by-scene
and I told her that.
I was like,
"Oh, there's this great bit
where I get by a car
out of a plane and she's like,
"I have to stop you there.
What on Earth
is this movie about?"
[ laughter ]
But it was fun.
and the stunts is something
I've always really enjoyed.
I have two amazing stunt doubles
who I've worked with
for a number of years, now,
and we have a great little thing
going on where, you know,
our motto is that things
should look dangerous
while being safe.
That's not always the case.
You know, there's bangs
and bruises here and there,
but it's part of the job.
But, yeah,
being hit by the car --
My mum actually came to set
that day.
-Oh, wow. Did she know it was
Hit by the Car Day?
-No!
-Okay.
-And then, the next day,
after hit by the car,
was Drown in the Well Day.
-Wow!
[ laughter ]
-Mate, it was brutal.
-Yeah. I guess that would've
been awful,
if she like read the script
and said,
"I want to be there on the day
you get hit by a car
and I definitely want
to be there
on drown in the well.
-It's that thing for me like
whenever my mum and dad come
to visit set
is always the day
where I don't work.
It's always the day where I'm
in my trailer
and I have nothing to do
because they're like,
"There's a problem
with the sound stage,"
or they're
doing a different scene.
You're just,
"We need to wait for you."
So my parents were always like,
"Why are you so tired
all the time?
[ laughter ]
Like what is wrong
with our son?"
And then, obviously,
coming to set on those two days
consecutively, I was like,
"This is why I'm so tired
all the time."
-Yeah. You're like, you know,
"You get hit by a car
out of a plane
and buy Christmas gifts
for the whole family."
[ laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Hey, man, it is always a full
pleasure to have you here.
-Thank you.
-Keep up the great work.
for making time for us, Tom.
-It was a pleasure.
-You guys, that's Tom Holland.